winter is coming and now it's spoilers
time season four over done which means I
can finally talk spoilers I'm probably
going to end up jumping around I'll try
and keep a chronological in terms of the
order of things happen so let's start
with purple wedding Joffrey finally I am
annoyed though I had it spoiled for me I
actually it's worth pointing out right
now every single major event that shocks
the viewers I've had spoil for me every
single one the death of Ned Stark the
red wedding Joffrey died Oberyn Martell
all of them from different sources
different reasons but you know what the
show still does them so well it doesn't
matter I mean we were all eager to see
Joffrey die everybody watching the show
wanted Joffrey to die so not only did
they give us a wonderfully death for the
guy but they even gave us an episode of
him and his absolute worst to lead up to
us so that we would just enjoy it all
the more very well played and I like how
the mystery was played off as well
because at first we didn't know who he
killed him I mean it was pretty obvious
Tyrion didn't do it even though he was
gonna have to take the fall for the
thing but we didn't know who it was I
like that we didn't know right off but I
also liked it that they didn't stretch
that mystery out for too long you know
we got the answer it was Baelish working
with the Terrell's Elena Tyrell
specifically and you know that's not a
massive kind of conspiracy that's a
conspiracy you would totally buy so it
wouldn't have been worth stringing out
more than the couple episodes they did
it for again just really well pace
really well play you know since I
brought up Baelish I just gotta give a
shout-out to this guy he is just so
insanely sneaky and calculating and
manipulating and just so out for himself
and he's just playing the game so well
I'm really gonna be curious to see where
Sansa goes because she seems to have
turned a corner here it's all just
implied in this new outfit in this look
that we get from her at the very end but
that just those few seconds they imply a
lot as for the other Starks sister Aria
continuing down this path of where she's
such an amazing character and just
seeing how her experiences are shaping
her into into a killer then to abandon
the hound like she did and did go up and
now she's doing what all of us wanted
her to do at the end of set of the
second season go and learn the ways of
the faceless assassins they teased it
made us wait for almost two full seasons
now she's going and speaking of the
house I'm going to assume that the Hound
is dead if you've read the books you
know for certain which is the case don't
tell me I've had enough stuff spoil for
me but I have to assume the Hound is
dead he was left to the situation where
there's no reasonable way that he's
gonna get out of that but what a way to
go down him and Brienne of Tarth that
fight this was like a Godzilla fight
this was just two big strong creatures
just beating the hell out of each other
oh it was brutal it was awesome and I
the minute they started fighting I had
two conflicting thoughts thought one was
this is gonna be so good and thought to
us I don't want them to fight cuz the
one who's gonna die and I like them both
Daenerys having to lock up the dryness
that hurt
that really did hurt that was a painful
moment to have to watch her do that
she's actually doing with her offspring
what Roose Bolton should really be doing
with Ramsay lock him away and then
there's what the title of last episode
dealt with children the children these
we've got these sort of fairy elf like
characters which on paper I should be
really annoyed by because I've said
before the more magical mystical
elements of the show I don't care for as
much I like it when it's about the
people but somehow this still works for
me maybe it's because it's been building
to it for so long I've had enough time
to kind of just live with the notion I
mean I wasn't expecting elves to show up
but the idea that bran and his little
crew was working through something that
was very much going to be a mystical
thing I was prepared for a mystical
answer I got a mystical answer and I was
okay with it Oberyn versus the mountain
squish Wow now like I said the fact that
he was going to die I did have spoiled
for me so I knew going in he wasn't
gonna come out of this fight alive but I
was not ready for what we got I honestly
think that is the most brutal hard to
watch death I've ever seen in any visual
medium film television comic books
I cannot remember another death that has
made me cringe harder than that death
and even though I had it spoiled for me
I only had it's boy like right before
seeing that episode so prior to that I
thought ogre was gonna stick around
george RR martin you did it to us again
even though we see repeatedly characters
that on any other show would be allowed
to live being picked off we still think
oh well I'm sure they're not gonna kill
that one yeah they are with one big
exception tyrion tyrion lives going into
the last episode of this season i was
really afraid that they were going to
kill him I was just I was just having a
hard time figuring out how the heck he
can possibly not die in this now when
Jamie showed up to his door and let him
out that was a scenario I considered
like well if he's gonna get out Jamie's
gonna set him free that's the only way
that this can work but as he was leaving
and he's going down the hallway he's
gone up the stairs he's going through
the castle I'm thinking to myself this
is too easy something else is something
else has got to happen this is gonna go
wrong and I thought and my first thought
was he's still gonna die he's gonna come
so close just gimme and he's still gonna
die like Searcy found out that Jamie was
gonna let him go and set up some other
trap or something well that isn't what
happened but I was right on my instinct
that something else had to happen Shay
you know it now makes me appreciate the
fact that she was around for as long as
she was is she still annoyed be
especially in season three I think maybe
they overplayed it slightly but if they
hadn't had her around if they hadn't had
Tyrion get his hung up on her as he did
and have her be as believable in her
apparent return of his affection then
that payoff where he chokes her out and
kills her wouldn't have been as powerful
as it was and then we get to talk
I win who saw this coming I mean as soon
as Syrian open the door he's got the
crossbow I'm like that guy's not getting
out of that [ __ ] or alive but up until
that moment I never want to guess that
Tywin was not gonna make it through the
end of this season but the thing is not
only his time when such a good
manipulator she's so good at making
himself not the target coz there's just
there's bigger show your targets for
people who want to have a bone to pick
with the Lannisters whether it's whether
it's the current Sita ki it was Joffrey
now it's Tommen or it's someone like the
mountain it's like he's really good at
getting being controlled but not being
the targets so I had no reason to think
he was gonna die well he's gone now and
Terry runs off and Varys joins them and
I think the two of them together he's
got to be a really interesting dynamic
and really that just leads me into the
fact that the entire world has changed
for this show the landscape is
completely different
the players are completely different the
scope is completely different everything
is different by the end of the season
you realize them that who sits on the
Iron Throne
doesn't matter and we know that now
because pretty much every major player
from the first season first two seasons
even is dead but the story continues
because the story is bigger than these
characters and it's bigger than what
they're even after but this season is
easily the best season since season one
it may even surpass season one as the
best season in my mind it's just so
amazing it's fantastic it ends so
strongly it started so strongly there
were fantastic little climaxes mini
climaxes throughout the season as well
as bigger overarching ones leading up to
the end it was just so well constructed
on an episode by episode basis and as
the season I've really only got one
complaint and it's the one that a lot of
people have had and that was the rape
not rape we don't know scene between
Jaime and Cersei now I alluded to the
scene before I didn't talk about
specifically what it was because I was
doing spoiler free stuff but ultimately
here's where I land I mean here's what I
have a problem with it it's
inherent problem with what happened a
lot of people took very deep offense and
really for a lot of people cemented the
show in their mind is being painting
misogynistic I don't feel the show is
but I absolutely see where they're
coming from for people who think that
now that wasn't the reason I have a
problem with what happened the reason I
have a problem with what happened is it
didn't change anything I mean seriously
I I cannot think of any way in which the
interactions between jaime and cersei
were affected by that if that hadn't
happened the scenes between them
following that event I don't think would
have changed even a little bit which
then just makes it completely not worth
it I mean if you're gonna do something
that challenging for the character ISM
for the audience it needs to mean
something you can't do that for no
reason have it not impact anything and
so far as I can tell it didn't impact
anything and that's why it bothers me
and that's why it annoys me because it
served no point to be fair I feel like
the people behind the show thought it
was more ambiguous than it then it
actually came off it came off really
like rape I think they were aiming for
something a little more ambiguous like
does she really wanted implying that
maybe she did it but they the final
product didn't deliver that but really
that's it one minor quibble amongst 10
episodes of gloriousness I mean if I had
any other issues with any other episodes
I can't even remember them now that's
how minor they were so I'm both
incredibly excited and incredibly
nervous about the next season because
like I said the landscape has completely
changed and that's a really big risk for
a show like this to take and it's
throwing so many characters into such
completely new situations and being
paired with new people and stuff like
that but you really have to wonder is
this all gonna play out slightly nervous
but a lot of confidence and a lot of
excitement so let me ask you this four
seasons into the show what's your
favorite season I do think for me it's
gonna be this one but what was yours any
particular reason for that drop
something down on the comments and let
me know and until next time this council
is adjourned